STEPHANY BELLOMO:
All right, so I'll
start off with our
first question here.
This is a little
bit of a softball.
Hopefully this will be
a fun one to answer.
And by the way, I
actually took some inputs
from the panel members
on which questions
they wanted to start
off with, so they
do have their
preference in here.
So the first one is, what
are your biggest release
or operations nightmare stories?
What was the cause, and how
did you recover from that?
And we'll just start from
you Armen, and then go down.
ARMEN GAPARANIAN:
The biggest nightmare
is actually shipping
the wrong bits
to the wrong users on
the wrong platform.
Another one is getting
your systems compromised,
and other people being
able to introduce malware
into your shipping product,
and you not knowing about that.
So those are--
STEPHANY BELLOMO: And how
did you recover from them?
Or did you change
your processes?
Or did you make any--
ARMEN GAPARANIAN: Have
we hit any of that?
No, we have not hit it, but
that would be terrifying.
And a lot of our
security analysis
was around that-- preventing
that from happening.
STEPHANY BELLOMO: OK.
So you've made some changes.
What kind of changes
did that prompt?
ARMEN GAPARANIAN: Locking
down our networks.
Even the rest of our
own organization,
we're on our own separate VPN.
Having different sets
of keys on the machines,
depending on which
type of jobs are
going to run on those machines.
So let's say community members
or people who are still
gaining their trust
can still trigger
some jobs in our systems.
We have something called the try
server, and on the try server,
they can try their jobs.
So separating our
systems according
to what will be run
on those systems,
and minimizing who has
access to those systems.
STEPHANY BELLOMO: OK.
Good answer.
JOHN O'DUINN: That's
of the ones that
used to keep me awake at night.
You make all this
time and effort
to make a really efficient
delivery process.
If somebody manages to put
something bad in there,
you've just made the
world's most efficient
malware distribution system.
And that's not the way you
want to end your career.
That's not a good move.
So it's something
we obsessed about.
And there are
companies around here
that have been hit by that.
They've had to stand up
and fess up and say, yeah,
our build infrastructure
was compromised,
and we're sorry for
the last few releases.
We think it's OK but-- that's
really embarrassing to be in.
So it's something
we've fretted about.
We've gone
super-ballistic any time
we find a machine that we're
in any way suspect about,
and we lock it down, and find
out it was a false alarm.
So we've had a few false alarms,
but we've never had a real one.
My other different
scenario is soon when
I joined Mozilla-- it
hasn't happened to me yet
at Hortonworks--
soon after I joined
Mozilla, one of our
machines blew up.
It turned out to be
the only machine that
did this critical task, and
nobody knew to recreate it,
and there was no back-up.
And everyone was
standing around me
going, well, you're
the build guy.
Sorry, it's all trees closed,
no development, no ability
to ship.
So backups-- timely
backups, that you actually
know the backups are working.
So try practising the restore.
PAT SHRIVER: Yeah, he just
reminded me, actually,
of my worst nightmare.
It had been so bad,
I'd forgotten it.
I'm sitting with a
VP, and he's going,
what do you mean you don't
know where the compiler is
to be able to reproduce
code for an SNMP fix
that we needed to
get immediately.
So the value of backups-- we
had them, but we had to go
find them in some
vault somewhere.
And so we did recover from
that, and from that day forward,
I always had systems
that I could reproduce.
And this is from-- not Google,
but from a previous company--
where I had to go back
and reproduce things five
or six or seven years
old on a regular basis.
Because there's
hackers out there
that kept on trying to break--
Cisco was the company--
and trying to break that
code on a constant basis.
Thank you, John,
for that reminder.
Never want to do that one again.
The other one is actually
sitting and watching
after a release goes
out and data corruption
bugs happening, and this,
again, at a previous company.
So I've been at Google for
only about eight months.
And so I did hear some of the
horror stories of my peers,
but I actually was asked
not to repeat some of them.
But watching data
corruption happen,
and having to go out
actually pull releases away
so people would be downloading
any more-- so that they
wouldn't be doing an upgrade
that would be failing for them.
And what we found is we
weren't testing well enough.
We needed to really do a
deep dive on our testing
and make sure that we were
testing as our customers were.
So that was a huge
lesson learned.
PETER RIGBY: Mine is--
so we talk about freedom,
having a lot of freedom in
terms of what you're putting
into the product, military
software-- some of the people
I was talking to, they're
developing one set of features,
and then all of a sudden,
they have a general coming
in and saying, this
is the thing that we
need in the next
release, and it has
to go operational
in Afghanistan.
And you're like, what?
So not having that
much control over what
features you're
actually releasing
can be pretty terrifying.
LIMING ZHU: I'm a
researcher, so I just
want to ask another general
question before this all
finishes up.
Basically, what are
the research questions
researchers can do to help?
I see a lot of-- it's
about risk management.
It's about cost drivers, and
some of the things we do.
But in your mind, what's
the top one or two things
that over long
term-- researchers
do research quite
slowly sometimes.
It's not like we're going
to have a solution tomorrow.
But looking forward, what
needs to be researched?
Thank you.
PETER RIGBY: So also being a
researcher, one of the things
that I'm really interested in
is this whole rush-to-release
process, which is-- if you
have a year-long release,
people are going to want to push
their stuff into that release
whether it's ready or
not, whereas if you have
a week-long release,
you can say,
just get on the next train.
One thing that we're trying to
do is actually quantify that.
So intuitively, I think
everyone agrees with that.
But what we'd like to do is
show that the features that
are rushed in, do
they actually produce
more customer reported defects?
So actually tying changes
that are done really
quickly and pushed
in very quickly--
do those end up having
more customer problems
than the ones that are done
in a more normal, stable way
of pushing new features?
JOHN O'DUINN: I have a
slightly different slant
on the same one,
which is-- I think
if I could ask for
anything with a magic wand,
I'd ask for tools that would
actually help us do our job.
So specifically, when I think
of recurring pain points,
one is manually-maintained
build dependencies
that are accurate at
some point in history,
but quickly become not, and then
becomes everyone's recurring
pain to try and figure out.
So you end up overcompensating
and doing full [INAUDIBLE]
builds just to be sure.
Because you don't trust
the dependencies to always
be accurate.
One.
Two is not knowing which
test out of gazillions
of hours of tests
actually should
be run for this code change.
So you end up, again,
overcompensating out
of paranoia and
run this whole set.
Or you try and hand
pick something,
but it's a scary process.
And that's because we don't
have tools that would tell us,
hey, this piece of code--
and some code coverage tools
sort of help-- but
this piece of code
really is being impact--
these tests would check that.
I think better than
that would be great.
PAT SHRIVER: Absolutely.
+1.
That's what I was going to say.
Source-to-test is
sometimes what it's
called, or test deminification.
And I know Google
does it really well,
but they've got a full
structure with the build system
to be able to know
your dependencies.
But that's not true
for other companies.
So that would be awesome
to be able to figure out
an awesome source-to-test--
whenever you want to call it--
but how do I know to run the
right tests at the right time.
ARMEN GAPARANIAN:
One question I've
been having for
the longest time--
I'm probably gonna be
going and start asking it,
is at Mozilla we run
tests on Windows 7,
Windows XP, Windows
8, 10.6, 10.7 10.8,
Ubuntu 12.04, Ubuntu 64-bit.
What is the right set of
platforms that you actually
need to be testing for
your code to be good?
For instance, I don't
want to be disrespectful,
Linux user base
is not that large.
Why do we still run
32-bit builds of Ubuntu?
Or some people
say, oh you've got
to run many versions
of Mac, because we
have many developers there.
However, in that case, we
should be running tests
on Windows Vista,
because there's
more users on Windows
Vista than Mac users.
So a way to analyze that and
figure out what is useful
and what it's not.
CHUCK ROSSI: This is a question
more for the practitioners
and specifically for Google.
Maybe you can start first.
PAT SHRIVER: Help
me, Google folks.
CHUCK ROSSI: What are you
most proud about with your
build and release system now?
If you had to point to one
thing, the thing that you feel
like you do really well, or
some tool, or some process,
or some part of the system
that is the thing you're
most proud of, or
the thing you want
to talk about the
most, or the thing
you want to see replicated
in other places?
PAT SHRIVER: Actually,
that one's real easy.
And the thing I would
have loved to have had
is-- we call them
blaze and tap here,
but it's basically
the build system
and the continuous
integration system.
65 thousand lines of
code of test run per day
are just amazing,
against every check
in that happens-- pre-check
in, post-check in--
and it's at scale.
My memory doesn't serve me.
I can pull up the stats, but
that's what's amazing here.
And so being so
new, and coming in
and hearing about
it from the outside,
but seeing it in practice--
yeah, there's warts.
Nothing's perfect.
But it's just amazing.
CHUCK ROSSI: And you'll open
source that soon, right?
PAT SHRIVER: I'm going to
take the fifth on that one.
JOHN O'DUINN: If I had
to think of anything,
I'd say it's in the
context of open source.
I've done release engineering
in a lot of non-open source
companies, and Mozilla
and Hortonworks
are the two that I've been
in that are open source.
I think it's very interesting
to show a couple things-- one,
that open source does not
mean half-baked or amateur.
It can actually mean
state of the art.
And proving that, and proving
that in a way that's profitable
and that actually attracts
attention, and also shows
the way, like hey, if
you do it this way,
it could actually
make your life better.
So Mozilla was
pretty cool for that.
Hortonworks is also
very cool for that.
And they're non-trivial
engineering problems.
Closed source companies
have something simple,
like you know the
permission of all the people
who connect into your system.
What if it's someone
you've never met before?
Are they really a good person
trying to give you a patch,
or are they some
evil person trying
to do something nefarious?
And how do you know
what to do there?
So I think those are really
complex problems, and kind
of cool.
BORIS DEBIC: There's
something I want
to add since I'm a Googler, and
I can answer Chuck's question.
One thing that may be too
late for the bigger companies,
but there's going to be
people watching here who
are in start-ups.
There's a lot of economic
activity right now starting up
in Silicon Valley, in the east
coast, Texas, you name it,
Europe.
You probably want to start
thinking about open sourcing
things and using open
source, meaning, I guess,
interacting with open source,
from the get go of the company.
Because if you start building
your own tools with open source
standards in mind-- like
not throwing stupid comments
in the codes, which really
lack-- your manager in five
years will come and say, hey
we should open source this.
And then you're-- yes, but
then we need to rewrite this
and maybe make it nicer.
So if you actually adhere
to open source standards
from the beginning, it will
make that transition easier.
When you make that
transition, when
you open a tool to the
open source community,
you will get--
you know, you guys
have opened some of your stuff--
you get immediate response.
You get bug fixes.
You get new features for free.
I mean we're getting the
same [INAUDIBLE] Androids.
You're probably
seeing the same thing.
And others in the room
will be doing the same.
So the takeaway
would be, if you're
a company that is
starting, don't
make the mistake
that Google made.
We built an incredibly
scalable infrastructure,
but also incredibly
baroque, so to speak.
And there's a lot of
fixing going on right now.
So don't make that mistake.
Start open source
minded from the get go.
PETER RIGBY: I'll answer it too.
So in my Ph.D., I looked at
peer review and open source
projects, and so I interviewed
a lot of Linux developers.
And they use almost
no automated tests,
but they have a really, really
strong peer review process.
So their commit
logs are massive.
It describes exactly
why everything
is changing, which machines
it's been, who else
has tried it, all
these other things.
And Linus Torvalds
will come along
and say, it's not that
this feature isn't good,
it's just that not enough
people have talked about it.
So it's hard to test the kernel,
I think, is one of the reasons,
but you can get similar
results by having
this trust-- this triangle
of trust-- where you really
review everything very tightly.
And I think that ties
into your karma thing too.
I mean, the pyramid of
trust, with Linux and then
the lieutenants,
and so on, it also
encourages good quality code.
NIRMAM SANDESARA:
A few people have
talked about we have
automation and tools
were the other person can go out
and push things to production.
So I have been
going-- I for Twitter,
and there is a culture
where, for PCI compliancy,
developers should
not have access
to products and boxes
and things like that.
So I wanted to get your
thoughts on how-- what release
engineers, what's the
role of a release engineer
when developers just have
access to production boxes?
CHUCK ROSSI: This
gets in a tricky area
because SAS and Sox
compliance, and there's
all sorts of things.
What I understand from it,
and you can't take this
as coming from anyone who--
not a lawyer-- the way
we deal with it is through
rigorous auditing and logging.
So the Netflix
model, where you're
all given the keys
to the kingdom
and can go about your business
is great, but in my experience,
it has pacified the auditors
if when they come in,
we show them exactly how we
log, how the code gets in,
all the hooks in place, and
the hooks are all secured.
We can log every path of
everything that went in.
We can log who touched
what production machine.
So the access is all there,
but it is strictly logged.
And the lodging is
scrutinized and locked down.
We actually did--
and we publicized
this-- we did a red team event.
Our security infrastructure team
did a red team event against us
that I was part of.
And what that means is we
actively got grey hat people
in a secure building
in our campus who,
through proxies through China,
attacked our infrastructure
by tricking a developer to
click on a link in a mail,
which gave them access to a box.
And they did this under our gaze
while we watched them do this.
And we were able to basically
see, did our stuff work?
Where did it fall down?
Where did the grey
hat get through?
And after that, we
did the full audit
and understood where we
had to harden things up.
So that's the extent to
which we care about this,
and we tested it, which
not a lot of companies
would have the cajones to do.
It is actually kind of scary to
watch some guy go through China
proxies to penetrate your whole
system, which was interesting.
JOHN O'DUINN: To take
the Mozilla example,
the scenario we were
concerned about there
was that we didn't want a
developer-- the nefarious
activity was one thing.
The other possibility
would be somebody
who's just trying to
make things better
by installing their locally
modified version of a compiler,
because there's a
slightly better optimizing
with a new version,
or it's a beta version
of the next compiler
or something.
And then we would accidentally
use that in production
to ship a production
release out.
That was actually an
operational concern
we had because we had
cleaned up a mess from that.
So what we did was we
said, OK, lock down access
was part of how we dealt
with the security part.
And then also if
somebody actually
wanted to get one of those
machines, we had a way to route
that you could get
access to that machine.
And then when you
were finished with it,
we would reset-- total
reformat, because it
was a human free reimage
back into production job.
Slightly different use case.
LIMING ZHU: I don't
have an answer,
but I just want to
clarify something
we get a bit confused.
Today we talk a lot
about release engineering
being helping developers.
So the operation,
the operators, what's
the relationship nowadays?
We heard about configuration
management and release
engineering have
interesting interactions,
but what do release
engineers say operators--
The operation guy, the
traditional IT operators?
What's their role in all this?
JOHN O'DUINN: I think
there's a lot of overlap.
DevOps is a popular term
these days-- everything
from what the developer is
doing through to an operations
person, and
everything in between.
I think you can change
the label on the front,
but the actual
nature of the work
in terms of understanding
one population figuring out
how to build a pipeline
and then figure out
this other operational
side, and be able
communicate between
these different groups,
is what we would call
release engineering.
It's not a great answer,
but it's the best I have.
LIMING ZHU: I just
feel when we go
to operators, some
of the DevOps meet up
with a lot of operators
in it, the culture there
is quite different
from developers.
They are more experienced
sharing, level-up
like Kung-Fu masters, and
they automate themself out
of the job.
But on the other hand, they seem
to consider human judgment--
experiences, really-- much more
important than [INAUDIBLE].
Just an observation.
GREGORY GROSSMEIER: My name is
Greg from Wikimedia Foundation.
Back to the open source thing,
obviously-- because we're
one of the largest sites that
is completely open source,
I think I can count
the number of packages
that we run in
production that aren't
open source on three fingers.
I think it's less than a hand.
I think it's three things.
MaxMind database
being one of them.
For us, we have
a large community
of contributors contributing to
our core product-- Media Wiki
software that powers
all of our sites, which
is slightly different
than some other use cases
more similar to-- I can't
point to you anymore,
to your use case of Firefox.
You have open source
contributors there.
What have you learned, and what
changes at that kind of scale
do you make when you want to
do fast iterative development
and deployment, when you have
a larger community than just
people you pay in house?
What are the concerns
and trade-offs
that you've made throughout
the years in that respect?
JOHN O'DUINN: The
short question,
rephrase the question was, what
kind of operational concerns
are there, what kind
of operation changes
do you have to make, if
some of the people who
are going to be making code
changes and not in your employ?
And then what?
There is a trust--
actually trust or karma,
if you want to use the
karma word-- at least all
the open source projects
I've been involved in,
you can make a
proposal for a change,
but you can't just come
along and start making,
here, I know how to
rewrite a kernel.
Come on.
Get out of the way.
Let me do it.
You don't do that.
You can propose
a patch in a bug,
and you have someone else
who's been around for a while
and has built a reputation.
So you have that
trust hierarchy.
So the initial person who
comes along out of the blue
does not have commit privileges.
And you earn those
stripes over time.
And once you
actually have enough
commit privilege
stripes earned, then you
could actually do reviews of
someone else and LAN those.
But you have other
super-reviewer super stripes,
if you like.
I think that's
one human process.
And that is enforced
for employees as well
as non-employees equally.
Two, is it does
totally change around
how you handle-- where
do you put your source
code repository?
Do you lock it behind VPN, or
do you put it out in the public?
Or how do you trust if it's
accessible from the outside?
And there's some
things that would
make a lot of closed
source companies
nervous, in terms of where
you place critical machinery.
And then you have to be
super-precise and careful
with those machines because
you care about them.
So where is your bug database?
What do you mean it's accessible
from the outside world?
Where is your source
code repository?
What do you mean,
it's accessible?
So there's things
like that you have
to do that are probably
unnatural for a closed source
company, so you have
to be super safe.
Those are the operational
tooling things.
I think the human culture
thing about reviews--
I would recommend, even if
you're not in an open source
environment, you should other
people look at your code.
People make typos, right?
And you'd be amazed
the amount companies
I've worked with that
didn't have that.
They just-- Well, we all
know what we're doing.
We never make mistakes.
GREGORY GROSSMEIER:
It's a hard question,
because we also have the
dual-- so my title is
release manager, which
kind of confuses people,
because I deal mostly
with the deployments.
And we also have the release
of Media Wiki, the software,
that tarballs every six
months, which I don't really
care about, because I
don't run those things.
I run the stuff that
gets updated every week.
So there's competing
interests there
with developers that are
wanting to maintain, god forbid,
an Oracle database back end.
Again, I don't care
about it, but how
does that affect our QA and
testing and beta cluster,
and all that kind of stuff?
I don't know if there's any
other organizations that
have this similar
type of pullings going
on with a tarball that
goes out to third parties,
and then the same code
goes out to production,
and that kind of stuff.
JOHN O'DUINN: Yeah.
Mozilla would ship out
to-- same source change set
would go to desktop
browsers, would
go to separate build
Android browser,
separate build to
handset Firefox OS.
Hortonworks is doing a
similar sort of thing,
in terms of taking
in code changes
and delivering them to
different places, too.
It's tricky.
It's where release engineering
is a tricky, fun thing.
SHANE MCINTOSH: We've heard a
lot about the different roles
that release engineering
plays in projects and teams
and so on.
I'm wondering where you
think-- so the practitioners
in the group-- where you
think release engineering
provides the most value
to an organization.
Is it in tooling?
Is it in the whole pipeline?
CHUCK ROSSI: In my view
it's the-- the word
I like is the adult supervision.
If you're in the
management of a company,
you want to have some
belief that there's
somebody or something
between the chaos that
is your development environment
and the poor suckers who
are going to get your product.
So I think the value that I've
provided in the many release
engineering jobs
I've had out here
in the valley is
that that management
team, that executive, that
CEO, knows that, OK, there's
that grumpy little guy called
Chucker who's going to manage
this for me and things
aren't going to go wrong.
Or if they are,
we're going to be
able to fix it and
react and get better.
So I think the fact that-- we
sit at this critical junction
of the chaos of development
and the gold standard
that your customers expect,
it all comes through us.
So that's always been
my pitch to-- when
I'm pitching to
come to a company
or trying to get a job,
that's the value proposition.
I have to actually say that when
I went from Google to Facebook,
Facebook didn't have
my position there.
There was no release
engineer on the job site.
This is 2008.
And I just looked for some
random engineering job.
And I just submitted my resume
attached to it, saying, listen,
I'm not applying for this
job, but this is what I do.
And I had to make that value--
they didn't know squat.
These dummies came
from college that
had never had a
job in their life.
This is not recorded-- Oh shoot.
So I had to make the
proposition that, listen,
this is what I do.
This is why you need it.
And this is what I
will protect you from.
And just give me these
problems, and I'll solve them.
And if it doesn't work
right, we'll fix it.
So that was the big
value part that I found.
GREGORY GROSSMEIER: For
the Wikimedia foundation,
we started out as the
prototypical cowboy type place.
It is what you think
it is, in a way.
It was a completely open
organization that anyone could
do anything, and we had
sysadmins that had access,
but it was uncontrolled
in a lot of ways.
And over the years, we started
to get a little bit more
grown up, or methodical,
about our processes.
And the growth of our
release team-- quasi
call it that even-- is even
just a virtual team in itself.
The people on the release team
are not just doing release
all the time.
They're splitting their time
between other things as well.
We're still at that size where
that's the world we live in.
But still with that
amount of time we do have,
we've brought sanity
and more infrastructure
to our ability to do things.
So you can go from a
roughshod kind of place
to a place that pushes code
every week with basically
the same release
process as Facebook,
with the weekly and
then back ports.
And it works really well for us.
And it wouldn't be possible with
the amount of 3 1/2 people that
we have working on it.
NIRMAM SANDESARA: How
I would define it is,
we usually manage
chaos in the company.
Everyone relies on us
to deploy every day
and make sure our
site doesn't get--
no fail whales, no
robots on twitter.com.
So usually, it's mostly--
people rely on us,
and it's just building trust
with them most of the time with
all our product managers, or
our VPs and stuff like that--to
maintain a pretty heavy schedule
doing deploys all the time
and then making sure that
we don't break the site.
PETER RIGBY: When I'm going
to be teaching a release
engineering course or just even
a lecture in one the classes--
one concept that I should be
teaching them, and one tool.
What would you like see?
NIRMAM SANDESARA: So
one of the concepts
would be faster deploys.
It could be through-- we use
something called Mortar, which
is a BitTorrent protocol
to deploy faster.
But there could be some other
better ways to faster deploys.
CHUCK ROSSI: One thing I want
you to get in their heads
would be some way to get
that operational awareness.
I'm trying to think of
a good way to do it.
We could talk, or we
could think about it.
But some way to tell
them that they're not
divorced from the process
of getting stuff out.
When I came up through computer
science in the '80s and '90s,
worked out here-- as
computer scientists,
we did not dirty
our hands dealing
with getting stuff out the door.
You through it over the wall,
and you went on with your life.
So something in a setting
that says, listen,
your responsibility, your
job as a computer scientist
doesn't end when you commit
to master and walk away.
So some way you
can tell them it's
on you to get it
out all the way.
PETER RIGBY: And a tool?
CHUCK ROSSI: A tool?
Obviously, we used to be called
build guys-- a good build tool.
I like Buck, which we've done.
Buildbot.
Just get familiar
with the configuration
files and the hooks and
the expandability of a good
build tool that gives
you the framework
to start building the
scaffolding for this,
so you can do it painlessly.
GREGORY GROSSMEIER: I
think from my perspective,
it's getting the real
world example use
cases of the full process,
from master to user, in web
or mobile or whatever.
There's a big gap there,
and it's not a chasm
that you can just
throw things over.
And what those
pieces are, and what
the best practices
of each step is.
PETER RIGBY: Do you have
publicly available-- you
have talks, or is publicly
available process documents
that we can distill?
I like doing case
studies because it
doesn't put the
students to sleep.
So this is, I think,
an excellent idea,
where you go through the
Facebook or the Wikimedia.
It would be great to have those
case studies because they're
like, oh, Facebook,
or Wikimedia.
They can tie it down
instead of general concepts.
Yeah, you have them as well.
Thanks.
GREGORY GROSSMEIER: The
pitch I gave last year
at this was, if you want to see
any little bit of what we do,
it's there in
Puppet on our repo.
It's public.
Everything is there
except for our password.
CHUCK ROSSI: That's
your ultimate.
The Wikipedia guys are
the ultimate example
of how you can do that.
We're probably a close
second, because we
are ridiculous with
the amount of stuff
that we just-- like all
the stuff I told you today
and my other talk
about front end,
are essentially the onboardings
I give to people when
they start at Facebook.
You're getting the
same information.
So those are two
really great examples.
JOHN O'DUINN: I think one thing
is just a coding assignment.
If you could have
coding assignments
to give out to people as they're
learning to program, and then
your next coding
assignment, you're like,
oh you build on-- first
it's a binary tree,
now it's a B-Tree, or
whatever kind of thing.
Make it that the second
coding assignment
is to take someone else's code
that was checked in somewhere,
and what they hand to
you is a check-in URL,
so that they learn how to
do check-outs and check-ins.
And they learn the
cost of someone
having written cruddy code.
I think is one awareness thing,
as opposed to just writing
into master and running away.
I think is the other thing
is for release engineers
particularly, it's useful
to have different skills.
There's the coding
and engineering stuff
but there's sysadmin
machine networking mindset.
And there's the human
diplomacy communication skill
of being able to talk to
product management, sysadmins,
IT security guys, developers, VP
of eng, be able to communicate.
So if there was some way to
say that you would send people
into a communications class,
or require them to attend
some other classes that are
non-engineering to learn
to talk to non-engineers
more, I'm speaking of this,
I think that would
be very helpful.
AUDIENCE: One of the courses,
basically the architecture
course, I get them to go and
find a very small open source
project and contribute to it.
Extract the architecture--
and actually first I
get them to draw what they
think the architecture is going
to look like, and then
get them to extract it.
And they're like, whoa,
this is just a mess.
Exactly.
So I think it's really valuable,
and just adding that release
engineering aspect to it.
There's not many small
open source projects
that have testing.
So I get them to do a
refactory, and I'm like,
there should be a
test, but there isn't.
STEPHANY BELLOMO: Ok, great.
That was a great question.
I want to thank all of
our panelists that we had.
We're going to
move on real quick,
and close out with
another discussion.